today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video so I
was going to come in today and tell you
that a Democrat has a chance to defeat a
Republican in the state of Montana but
if I told you that it wouldn't be
accurate because it's not that a
Democrat has a chance to defeat a
Republican in Montana the truth is that
a Democrat is leading by seven against a
Republican in Montana this is a really
really big deal we'll talk about Montana
then we'll apply it a little bit broadly
in 2016
Donald Trump won Montana 56 to 36 over
Hillary Clinton 20-point win in that
state in 2014
Republican Steve Daines won his Senate
race over Amanda Curtis also by a big
margin by 1858 to 40 but incumbent
Republican Senator Steve Daines
who won in 2014 is currently down 7 -
Steve Bullock in the very red state of
Montana Steve Bullock is the current
governor of Montana according to the new
Montana State University poll released
yesterday he is ahead by seven against
the incumbent Republican senator now if
the name Steve Bullock sounds familiar
it should not just because he's the
current governor but he also was not not
particularly successful but he was in
the 2020 Democratic primary race for a
little while and even was in at least
one debate I don't remember now exactly
how many debates but he was in at least
one debate I think we've been talking
about the Senate balance in 2020 and
Democrats need to have a net gain of
three seats plus the presidency or a net
gain of four seats if Trump gets
reelected to take control of the Senate
now why what does that mean why does
that matter whether Trump wins or loses
if you have a Senate that's 50/50 the
tiebreaker is the vice president of
course if the tiebreaker is Mike Pence
that doesn't go
Democrats way so if Trump were to get
reelected Democrats would need to get to
51 seats if Biden wins they only need to
get to 50 so we're assuming and I
believe that it's a fair assumption that
Democrats are gonna lose the Doug Jones
seed in Alabama that's the special
election seat it used to be Jeff session
Senate seat jeff sessions was made
Donald Trump's beleaguered attorney
general so that seat was up for special
election Doug Jones won against the
Republican nominee who was serial
accused a sex assault or Roy Moore now
Jeff Sessions is trying to win his old
seat back and he's winning very very
handily in the polling in Alabama so
there's every indication Democrats are
gonna lose that seat in Alabama
so to net three you've got to find four
wins to net four you've got to find five
wins because you're gonna lose that one
seat so what are we looking at Arizona
we've talked about Arizona before Mark
Kelly against the incumbent Republican
martha mcsalley she is in the seat
previously held by John McCain the late
John McCain she's not won in the
election she was appointed their main
Sarah Gideon is doing well against
longtime incumbent senator Susan Collins
a Republican who's often disappointed
with Trump but eventually sides with him
in Colorado Cory Gardner is not doing
particularly well in North Carolina Thom
Tillis could lose which would be great
but now with the addition of Montana
this adds a new element now a few
caveats on the seven-point lead that
Steve Bullock has in Montana number one
it's 46 to 39 so it's a seven-point lead
but 46 plus 39 is only 85 that leaves 15
up in the air and sometimes that breaks
for the incumbent so that's one caveat
um one of the reasons that Bullock is
doing well in Montana is that as the
current governor as I told you he's done
really well with coronavirus he has a 70
percent approval on his handling of
coronavirus only a 48% approval for the
incumbent Senator Steve Daines in terms
of his handling of coronavirus of course
governors and Senators have different
roles
in the context of coronavirus 2020 could
quickly become Senate Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell's worst nightmare if
some of these races go the Democrats way
but it's up to us to make it so we need
to get out and vote and not assume any
single race in any state now I have
other outrageous news for Montana as
well there is a hypothetical
presidential polling being done I guess
at this point it's not really
hypothetical in the sense that Joe
Biden's the only candidate left Trump is
only ahead by five in the presidential
polling against Joe Biden in Montana
remember in 2016 Trump beat Hillary by
twenty in Montana now admittedly
libertarian Gary Johnson got five points
in Montana in 2016 so maybe that these
numbers need to be adjusted for that but
this is a big swing call it a 10-point
swing call it a 15-point swing if indeed
Donald Trump only wins Montana by five
it would be a very bad November for
Donald Trump does it pass the sniff test
that Trump is only up five in Montana I
don't know I honestly don't know these
are early numbers anyway we shouldn't be
assuming anything there's much to work
for but the Senate which a year ago I
would look two years ago I was saying
Democrats don't really have a chance in
November of 2020 for the Senate one year
ago I was saying it's possible but it's
a big uphill battle six months ago I was
saying it's possible now this is a real
possibility I don't I don't think it's
likely I think I still think if I had to
bet I would say you got to give me odds
to bet on Democrats in taking the Senate
but there is now a very clear path and
it is not a wholly unrealistic path
Democrats would need a couple of these
races to go against the incumbent in the
end that can be tough but a lot of good
races to get involved in and really
great numbers out of Montana we'll keep
following it I have a Red Alert
corruption story for you today this is
the worst of government to see I
previously reported to you that dr. Rick
bright former deputy assistant secretary
for preparedness and response for Health
and Human Services dr. Rick bright says
he was pushed out of his role
and he believes it's because he was
regularly going to the Trump
administration and saying were
unprepared to deal with coronavirus he
believes it's because he refused to go
out and promote the use of
hydroxychloroquine as a coronavirus
treatment despite Donald Trump doing it
publicly and despite the Trump
administration pushing dr. Rick bright
to do it he has been working on a
whistleblower complaint which he filed
yesterday it's devastating and we'll get
to it in a moment but the corruption is
that three days before Donald Trump
fired the Inspector General of Health
and Human Services who is the inspector
general that would have been receiving
and investigating this complaint from
dr. Rick bright Christie grim she was
replaced with the total Trump loyalists
what a coincidence
Trump couldn't stop the whistleblower
complaint so he made sure that the
person handling the complaint
investigating the complaint would be
someone loyal to him rather than someone
whose loyalty is to the facts and to
reality grim was already on Trump's bad
side because she was willing to publish
a report in January saying hey we have
huge shortages of PPE we're short on
testing supplies if we're going to deal
with a pandemic we were woefully
unprepared Trump didn't like it and this
was a great opportunity to get her out
before she had the opportunity to handle
dr. Rick brights whistleblower complaint
from clear out there will be no
dissension in the ranks Trump must be
placated all the time constantly or you
will be fired so that gets us to
yesterday dr. Rick bright files his
whistleblower complaint and if even 10%
of what's in it is true it is absolutely
stunning it is everything we feared it's
everything we've been suspecting was
going on in the Trump administration in
the lead up to the virus in December in
January and dr. Rick bright explains
that early coronavirus warnings that he
brought to the administration were
ignored let's check out some of what he
said yesterday during a press conference
time after time I was pressured to
ignore her or dismiss expert and
scientific recommendations and instead
to award lucrative contracts based on
political connections
in other words I was pressured to let
politics and cronyism drive decisions
over the opinions of the best scientists
we have in government and ultimately I
was removed from my position because of
my continued insistence that the
government invests funds allocated by
Congress hard-earned taxpayer dollars to
address the COBIT 19:00 and invest them
into safe and scientifically vetted
solutions so this is absolutely
devastating you can listen to the six or
seven minutes during which he outlines
everything that he alleges went on but
I'll tell you some of what it includes
dr. Rick bright says he went to the
administration and said were short on
supplies and masks Trump officials
didn't believe him not enough to do
anything about it he was right of course
he says that as his warnings about the
virus were confirmed the indifference
that he was experiencing turned to
outright hostility against him dr. Rick
bright says he was pressured to give
lucrative contracts to whoever the Trump
administration wanted I've told you that
there's been a lot of money made on
coronavirus and one of the ways is by
getting contracts with the government to
produce PPE or other things sweetheart
deals as we might call them Rick Wright
says he's blowing the whistle he says
they came to me they told me give the
deals to these particular companies and
of course we already knew dr. Rick
bright says he was pressured to promote
hydroxychloroquine as a treatment for
coronavirus he pushed back he said it's
not scientifically sound we should
really limit it to these trials much
like a dozen other medications that were
testing the Trump administration wanted
chloroquine promoted far and wide he
refused to do it and he was transferred
out of that role now the legal argument
is going to be more complicated for dr.
Rick brights lawyers his lawyers say
when he was warning the administration
about the lack of PPE and the lack of
coronavirus a danger more broadly that
his actions were protected by the
whistleblower protection act that is a
questionable case to make oh it's gonna
be difficult
I mean intuitively certain
colloquially it's accurate but the
counterpoint would be he may have been
ignored when he was blowing that when he
was raising alarm but it didn't violate
the whistleblower protection act
you could argue also that he wasn't
fully ignored but it's going to be a
difficult case to prove so we have two
issues here really we have dr. Rick
bright being pushed out after being
ignored that's tragic it's horrifying it
builds on what we've suspected for some
time that the Trump administration did
get early warnings about the virus but
ignored them at this point but we know
that that took place and dr. Rick bright
was just one piece of that the second
piece is Trump fired the person who
would be investigating ric reitz
assertions what use to us our inspectors
general if the president will just fire
the ones that actually investigate
things Trump doesn't want investigated
now we could deal with that there's a
bill that's meant to protect inspectors
general to Democrats wrote it Senator
Chris Murphy and Senator Jim Cooper and
under this bill the inspectors general
can't just be removed from office for
political reasons they could only be
removed for quote permanent incapacity
inefficiency neglect of duty malfeasance
or conviction of a felony or convict
involving moral turpitude that is a much
higher standard than Trump wants to stop
their investigations so he fires them so
we have a bill that's been written which
would deal with this good luck passing
it in a Republican Senate which reminds
us of the importance of helping
Democrats take control of the Senate in
November now of course Fox News Oh a an
whoever Hannity Rush Limbaugh they're
going to say about a bill like that look
at these Democrats trying to prevent bad
people from being removed of course
that's not what they're trying to do so
this is all catastrophic at every level
and sadly when we get to the question of
consequences it's up to us I mean listen
a what who's going to do anything to
Trump here all we can do is remove him
in November we've got to vote this
garbage of an administration out in
November because Trump's fired numerous
inspectors general there have been
consequences Trump has manipulated the
people in charge of even potentially
overseeing the actions or inactions of
the federal government it doesn't make a
difference really I mean it has not
there have been no consequences okay you
know a couple people went to prison or
going to prison for short short
sentences but the big malfeasance of the
constant corrupt crony capitalism and
distortions of reality from this
administration while covering up their
misdeeds by firing people and lying and
doing all sorts of other things there's
really been no consequence to that it's
up to us it's up to us to remove this
garbage in November I hope that we will
let me know what you think I'm on
twitter at D Pakman make sure you're
following me there and make sure you are
signed up to the all new David Pakman
show newsletter by signing up at david
pakman.com the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue to calm and use promo code David
you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay $5 shipping
that's promo code David you get your
first shipment of blue two completely
free and I've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com all right welcome back
today's new members of the day are
Cherise Smith and Shay cook thanks
Cherise and Shay very much appreciate
your support also a major thank you
today to today's sustaining member of
the day that's Tom Buckley tom has been
a member for almost five years join
these great people it takes mere seconds
to shut to sign up with just average
computer skills I promise you go to join
pakman.com we do have a coupon code
available this is 20/20 which will save
you 40% if you want don't feel obligated
but always available let's talk a little
bit about the trajectory the future
trajectory of the white house
coronavirus task force the news is that
donald trump is now thinking of
canceling the white house coronavirus
task force even as deaths again spiked
yesterday 220 350 in a single day and
this is this is like much of what Trump
has done in the last two months when it
comes to coronavirus which is just a bad
boneheaded idea but if your concern is
just propaganda and pretending that
you're doing a good job instead of
dealing with the virus this is exactly
what we would expect Donald Trump to do
the task force I'll remind you was
formed at the end of January this is the
task force where Mike Pence's I guess
the official head of the task force dr.
deborah birx is the response coordinator
you've got the Surgeon General on the
task force you have that Secretary of
Health and Human Services Alex SR on it
he's the one who initially put a former
dog breeder of labradoodles in charge of
the day-to-day doctor foul cheese on the
task force the Commissioner of the FDA
Steven Hahn is on it ben Carson is not
there's a whole bunch of people on this
task force now as it is the task force
has not been super concerned with health
and has been too concerned with politics
towards the end of the press briefings
we would see dr. Burks become more a
vector of disinformation than of science
and that was a horrible thing but at
least you had a task force that was
briefing
daily well the press briefings went
horribly wrong after the bleach
injection Fiasco we've seen those be
pared down really stopped at this point
we no longer see doctor foul tree or dr.
Burke's daily other than in corporate
media interviews and instead Donald
Trump has replaced the coronavirus press
briefings with these economic I guess
I'd call them economic agitprop events
with business CEOs and other
brown-nosing sycophants but the cases
aren't going down so if you are
prioritizing paying attention to the
data rather than whether Trump praises
CEOs we are still finding about 25,000
new coronavirus cases basically every
single day sometimes more sometimes a
little less and deaths again have spiked
yesterday 20 350 deaths in one day in
the United States a really bad number
and when you look at what's going on in
Italy when you look at what's going on
in Spain when you look at the curves and
then you see what's going on here it's
not good and meanwhile as I told you
yesterday CDC and FEMA have a report
which says they fear that deaths might
actually climb to 3,000 a day by June
first with maybe 200,000 new cases a day
now I hope that doesn't happen as you
all know politics don't play a role in
what I hope happens I don't hope we have
one single death for the purpose of
making Trump look bad or helping to
defeat Trump the case for that is very
clear there have been enough deaths I
don't want anyone to die hopefully it
won't happen but the numbers in a lot of
states aren't looking good here's Donald
Trump asked yesterday in Arizona about
the coronavirus task force Trump stopped
at a Honeywell mask required factory he
refused to wear a mask I'll talk about
that later but Donald Trump again
talking about we've just done great
about everything and at one point he
Trump walked around all day yesterday
with a piece of paper in his pocket
that was just a graph of the total
number of coronavirus tests which is
meaningless right we've talked about per
capita here is Donald Trump's answer and
it includes pulling out that piece of
paper when asked about why would you now
disband the coronavirus
task force everything and don't you want
to I need I choose to say that we've
done an incredible job in testing with
that being said we have some additional
including antibody tests coming out that
will even blow these numbers away but
nobody's done the job we don't you need
to continue to meet with the task force
to get this scientific expertise oh yeah
we will have certain people as an
example we have hospitals that we built
we have medical centers that we've built
we have people on the task force that
focus on that we have people on the task
force that's focused exclusively on
ventilators well we have more
ventilators now than anybody in the
world and we're helping France as you
know we're helping France Italy Spain
Nigeria we're just we're giving I think
250 to Nigeria we have many countries
that were helping but the ventilator
problem is solved so you don't need that
we have now a different it's sort of a
combination of safety and reopening so
we'll have something in a different form
but the task force for what we've done I
think everybody out there when they're
being very honest I think the job we've
done on testing will shortly be and
maybe even supersede Doug the job that
we've done on ventilators which people
can't even believe we had a call the
other day with the governor's so it goes
on for about an additional minute but as
you can tell there's no answer there's
no answer the question was should you
really end the coronavirus task force
when we are in the middle of a pandemic
and Trump says governors are happy we
have tons of ventilators and I have a
piece of paper with a graph about
testing it's striking me as
counterintuitive to end the task force
now and I want to point out one other
thing we've been watching the numbers
coming out of some of these early
openings southern states the states that
didn't have these are states that
weren't initially hotspots and they
insisted that they're good to go and
reopen the numbers aren't good look at
just one example out of Texas in Texas
cases have increased dramatically over
the last nine days Texas had 535 new
cases on April 27 that went up to 960
new cases on April 30 and that was up to
more than
1200 new cases yesterday now understand
the raw numbers are not the important
thing here the percentage increases are
if you see new cases continue to
increase in Texas at this rate there are
thirty four thousand cases will be more
than 50 thousand cases just ten days
from now and by then if the other
northeastern and West Coast states keep
seeing declines Texas will have
dramatically more active cases than any
of these early hotspots we can do a
similar analysis in other states I hope
none of this happens but the last thing
you need right now is to end the task
force and just focus on reopening since
its that reopening which may indeed
wreak havoc in a whole bunch of states
hope it doesn't happen it's what the
data is pointing to Donald Trump has
absolutely exploded in a childish
tantrum the likes of which we've not
seen for a while over what is really a
very well-done ad that mirrors the style
and format of an old Ronald Reagan ad
but goes right after Trump on his
handling of coronavirus and the Lincoln
project which has created the ad is
paying to run the ad during Tucker
Carlson's program on Fox News they are
claiming that they are going to keep
running these ads as we close in on the
November election now we briefly talked
yesterday about a few tweets that Donald
Trump sent about this and it isn't ad by
the Lincoln project the Lincoln project
is an anti-trump super pac George Conway
funded it founded and funded I think
rightly said and hilariously George
Conway is the husband of Trump's own
advisor Kellyanne Conway I would love to
know what a quiet night at home is like
with them at this point in time but in
any case it goes right after Trump on
coronavirus it's called morning in
America but morning spelled mo you are
an ing let's take a look at the ad
listen to the ad it's just a minute long
there's morning in America
today more than 60,000 Americans have
died from a deadly virus Donald Trump
ignored with the economy in shambles
more than 26 million Americans are out
of work the worst economy in decades
Trump bailed out Wall Street but not
Main Street this afternoon
millions of Americans will apply for
unemployment and with their savings run
out many are giving up hope
millions worried that a loved one won't
survive kovat 19 there's mourning in
America and under the leadership of
Donald Trump our country is weaker and
sicker and poorer and now Americans are
asking if we have another four years
like this will there even be an American
[Music]
project which is responsible for the
content of this advertising so like I
said they paid to run this during Tucker
Carlson's show on Monday night which may
be how Donald Trump first saw it which
is just great I mean you're going right
after Trump in the ad and you're also
going right after Trump by targeting the
Fox News audience and what is good about
this ad is that it gets right at the
heart of not just the lack of empathy of
Donald Trump's response to coronavirus
reporting death numbers when he does as
mere curiosities essentially but it also
goes after Trump's cronyism it goes
after Trump's indifference it goes after
Trump's inaction and it covers all of it
and it gets to the economic issues as
well and those may well be resonating
with Republicans in the context of who
they're going to vote for in November 60
seconds of a really well done ad and it
has sent Donald Trump into a complete
and total tailspin Trump started with a
series of tweets close to one in the
morning early Tuesday morning where he
wildly attacked George Conway and the
other Republicans that are involved in
this project saying quote brace
yourselves by the way quote a group of
RINO Republicans who failed badly 12
years ago then again eight years ago and
then got badly beaten by me a political
first-timer 4 years ago have copied
no imagination the concept of an ad from
Ronald Reagan morning in America doing
everything possible to get even for all
of their many failures
you see these loser types don't care
about 252 new federal judges two great
Supreme Court justices a rebuilt
military a protected second amendment
biggest ever tax and regulation cuts and
much more I didn't use any of them
because they don't know how to win and
they're so-called Lincoln project is a
disgrace to Honest Abe I don't know what
Kellyanne did to her deranged loser of a
husband moon face by the way moon face
interchangeably a slur against Asian
people Kelly uh George Conway I believe
is half Filipino also just a slur or or
an insult for people with certain
medical conditions her deranged loser of
a husband moon face but it must have
been really bad John Weaver lost big for
Kasich to me crazed Rick Wilson lost for
Evan McMuffin McMullen to me Steve
Schmidt and Reed Galvan loss for John
McCain Romney's campaign manager lost to
Big O and Jennifer horn got thrown out
of the New Hampshire Republican Party
they're all losers but Abe Lincoln
Republican is all smiles okay so that's
a mouthful that was close to 1:00 a.m.
Tuesday morning but it continued
yesterday during the day with Donald
Trump then tweeting quote most of the
money raised by the RINO losers of the
so-called Lincoln project remember RINO
means Republican and named only goes
into their own pockets with what I've
done on judges taxes regulations health
care the military vets choice and
protecting our great Second Amendment
they should all love Trump problem is I
beat them all this is the guy who is
close to being the leader of the free
world were it not for Angela Merkel he
probably would be this guy has access to
nukes he has access to nukes he's in
charge of responding to a hundred-year
pandemic and this is what he's tweeting
now understand the ad is really a parody
or a sort of satirize ation i don't know
if that's word a satirizing of an old
ronald reagan adage
says that they are copying it because
they don't have imagination no that this
is this is called satire this is called
turning something around morning in
America was the Reagan ad here is what
is being mimicked this is the original
Reagan ad it's morning again in America
today more men and women will go to work
than ever before in our country's
history
was interest rates at about half the
record highs of 1980 nearly 2000
families today will buy new homes more
than at any time in the past four years
this afternoon 6500 young men and women
will be married and with inflation of
less than half of what it was just four
years ago they can look forward with
confidence to the future it's morning
again in America and under the
leadership of President Reagan our
country is prouder and stronger and
better
why would we ever want to return to
where we were less than four short years
ago
[Music]
I find it funny that Trump attacks them
for copying it he doesn't seem to
understand this isn't a lack of
creativity this is taking a well-known
ad that was positive about a president
and tweaking it to expose the horrible
leadership of Donald Trump excellent job
by the Lincoln project doesn't mean I
agree with them
I'm not rehabilitation the image of
whoever right
but if they help us remove Trump for
something better than Trump then that's
a good thing and the next six months are
going to be wild if they keep putting
these ads together we'll have more
coverage of this ad on the David Pakman
show Instagram page at David Pakman show
also this weekend it's happening I am
going to be participating in a
transplant of my tomato sprouts from
indoors to outdoors in my urban garden
you're looking to follow the adventure
follow me on instagram at david Hawk
very serious stuff the david pakman show
at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world's
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at join
pakman.com coupon code saves you 40%
vote soon 18 welcome back to the David
Pakman show all right let's do a deep
dive into correcting lies this is
difficult in our current political
climate Donald Trump yesterday
absolutely collapsed like a house of
cards under basic questioning by ABC's
David Muir yesterday Trump was in
Arizona went to a mask factory didn't
wear a mask total propaganda visit but
in the middle of it Trump was
interviewed by David Muir of ABC he
didn't really do anything special other
than be a basic journalists asking Trump
specific questions and waiting for an
answer and Trump's disintegration Trump
became aerosolized let me put it that
way that was the degree of
disintegration it is really something to
behold I'm gonna do something that's a
real pain to do which is I'm going to
fact-check three minutes of a Trump
interview and it's soul I rattled that
you will notice it takes a lot longer
than three minutes to do the
fact-checking
and as usual more people hear the lie
very few hear the correction the
correction is more work this is what
we're up against but let's do it let's
do it together okay so let's start with
David Muir presents Trump with a quote
the quote is one you've probably heard
before Trump said fifteen cases are soon
going to go to zero let's dig in I'm
going to try to fact-check set you so
that you can understand how these lies
are spread and perpetuated and they
become actually like an alternative
truth to trumpets that they repeat let's
get into the first question here there
was one thing you said that
perhaps you could clarify you said this
this was at the end of February a whole
month of gun bye you'd stop travel from
China and you said of the cases here in
the US when you have 15 people and when
the 15 within a couple of days is going
to go down to zero that's a pretty good
job we've done
help me understand that moment did you
really think we were gonna have 15 cases
in the US and let me really I said even
like you would say worse than that I
said one person one time and it's true
it was a time when we had one person in
this country we knew about it we worked
on it but we had one person it mushroom
to 15 people mushroom other people were
coming and also from Europe so already
we have to think this through the
question was when you said we have 15
and they're going to go to 0 how did you
come up with that walk us through how
you decided 15 cases were going to go to
0 and Trump says well it was true you
know at one point we did have only 15
cases at one point we did have only one
case that wasn't a question and one tool
that's really important to have when
you're trying to parse lies from from
government officials or anybody is are
they answering the question that was
asked have they given an answer and
Trump has not the question was not did
we really only have 15 cases at one
point of course right I mean if we now
have 1.2 million official cases at some
point we at 0 you you have to go through
the number 15 to get there there's no
question about that that wasn't the
question the question was why did you
think 15 would go to zero Trump doesn't
answer it let's continue now Trump pulls
out this sad piece of paper he'd been
carrying around all day and it gets very
very gas-lit at this point take a look
don't forget but we're at more than a
million mitosis yeah in January ok let's
talk about cases you know why because we
have more testing than anybody else if
we test it as much as these countries
down here ok who don't do very much
testing at all look at Japan very little
testing there at the bottom of the rung
look at South Korea get so much
publicity the president of South Korea's
a friend of mine
president moon he called up he said what
you're doing with testing is amazing if
I tested this number of people instead
of this number of people I'd have far
fewer if I see this line goes all the
way up over seven million tests okay so
the graph that Trump pulls out is a
linear graph of the total number of
tests that were done and this is really
important to understand because it's one
of the key disinformation sources right
now
Trump brags we've tested more than seven
million people now that's true
but this is a country of 331 million
people I'm going to sound like a broken
record here but what matters is per
capita per capita testing the u.s.
testing seven million is different than
France testing seven million because
France has a much smaller population as
an example so when you look at a
sampling of testing per capita you would
see that for example Iceland a small
country for sure Iceland is second in
the world in testing per capita they've
tested about a hundred and fifty
thousand people for every million of
population now they don't even have a
million people Israel is 13th in the
world they've tested 49,000 people per
million Portugal is 15 Spain is 20th
Norway is 26th the United States is 41st
in testing per capita we've tested about
23,000 people for every million people
we have we are ahead of the UK for
example the UK is 45th so this is a live
Trump won't stop telling we are 41st in
testing per capita let's keep going with
the interview if I test it down here at
1 million tests I would have a lot fewer
cases - I understand the argument you're
making let me look at you question oh
but you understand there's a huge
disparity between 15 and more than a
million cases what was it an
intelligence failure where was the
breakdown that we didn't know the scope
of this
I closed the border if you want to use
that term I banned people from coming
into China there were approximately
40,000 Americans if you were in my
position you you would let them come in
you could ask Rhonda Sanchez great
governor Florida those people went
through quarantine they went through
tests they went through everything but
there were American citizens I had 11
come back then but I came in and what I
did is I said against many people
including Anthony Fauci who I liked very
much
including Deborah who I liked very much
the doctors and many other people again
Trump says he closed the border to China
now it's true that went into effect on
February 2nd but understand by that
point 45 countries had already closed
travel to China okay it's also not an
answer to the question an absolute
collapse of a performance by Donald
Trump
here's another portion Trump has
repeatedly used this phrase the
cupboards were bare when I came in and
what that means is Barack Obama left me
undersupplied and Trump has used the
term to talk about the military we've
already debunked that that's not true
and Trump has also applied this to PPE
for a pandemic here David Muir asks him
okay you know you've used this phrase
the cupboards were bare what did you do
to restock the cupboards and Trump
essentially says well you know I was
actually busy with impeachment take a
look you know you're three years into
your first term there now applying for
the job again what did you do when you
became president to restock those
cupboards that you say were bare well
I'll be honest I have a lot of things
going on we had a lot of people that
refused to allow the country to be
successful they wasted a lot of time on
Russia Russia Russia that turned out to
be a total hoax then they did Ukraine
Ukraine and that was a total hoax then
they impeached the President of the
United States for absolutely no reason
and we even had a hundred and
ninety-seven to nothing vote by the
Republicans understand my friends that
one of Donald Trump's main defenses of
how he handled
virus is I was given a bad situation by
Barack Obama and I fixed it I filled the
cupboards here he's given an opportunity
to say exactly what he did he could tell
us how he filled the cupboards and he
says well you know I was pretty busy
with impeachment I was pretty busy with
the Russia probe and all of that stuff
David Muir gives him the opportunity to
silence his critics and say exactly what
he did to fill the cupboards and he
can't do it now let me tell you the
truth and this this is sort of a bigger
picture story the truth is that Barack
Obama handed Trump a pandemic response
team and Trump disbanded it and bragged
about disbanding it in 2018 the truth is
Barack Obama handed Trump a pandemic
response playbook
69 pages and color-coded we've looked at
the document very good document all
Trump had to do was follow it and Trump
didn't follow it that's the truth and
Donald Trump unable to withstand just
basic questioning by ABC's David Muir so
Trump had to stop press briefings
because they were doing more harm than
good especially after that bleach
injection fiasco
now Trump is doing an actual sit-down
interview with someone other than Fox
News and it goes horribly wrong
Trump has no choice seemingly but to
just do propaganda roundtables with CEOs
because everything else is going
horribly wrong
okay let's talk a little bit about masks
briefly Donald Trump traveled to Arizona
yesterday went to a Honeywell facility
that is making masks because we have a
pandemic and people should be wearing
masks that factory requires masks and
Donald Trump refused to wear a mask
instead Trump wore goggles which is okay
I mean fine but it's a little weird
given that he didn't wear the mask Trump
was asked as he was leaving the White
House yesterday on his way to Arizona
will you wear a mask and Trump said I
will if it is a mask facility say it
I think it's a basque facility right if
it's a mask facility I will yeah I don't
know if it's a mask facility but honey
we're going to see honey well they have
done an incredible job when many fronts
and so I'm going to pay my respects to a
great company at a great state the state
of Arizona they make in 95 yeah they
make masks as Trump says if it's a mask
facility Trump says that he will wear
one well as you can see in this video
that we are playing there are safety
guidelines prominently displayed at this
Honeywell facility and they say please
wear your mask at all times in addition
to observing six feet of social distance
as well as using hand sanitizer and yet
here is Donald Trump standing 18 inches
from another guy wearing goggles but no
mask as the guy shows him a mask they
have a crate of masks in front of them
you couldn't parody this on Saturday
Night Live the factory policy is wear a
mask at all times and Trump puts on
goggles but no mask and his aides are
also now wearing masks now why do we
care about this is it just disaster porn
no we care about this because more than
60 million people in this country voted
for this guy many of those people see
Trump as a demigod and they do whatever
he does and if Trump goes to a mask
facility and he doesn't wear a mask it
encourages this exact type of behavior
that we don't need right now so we can
laugh it off we can say okay you know
Trump wore goggles and no mask he's just
personally kind of a weird dude or an
idiot but it doesn't really have an
impact this will fuel more right-wingers
not wearing masks and actually being
opposed to them this sends the message
that wearing a mask isn't that important
even when the policy of a location is
masks at all times it encourages people
to ignore it if they see Trump ignoring
the policy that's an enlarged print on a
TV and probably multiple TVs Trump's own
administration has said covering your
mask is better than not cover covering
your face rather is better than not
covering your face if you don't have a
mask wear a scarf Trump said well they
had masks
it's a mask factory I would wear one if
they require it but then he doesn't and
of course that puts people around Trump
at risk and it puts Trump himself at
risk the message that is being sent his
masks or no big deal coronavirus is no
big deal everything's fine and yet two
thousand three hundred and fifty people
died in the United States yesterday but
remember he's wearing goggles this is
the same guy who looked at his solar
eclipse directly so it's not a question
of Trump's intelligence that seems to be
lacking but how does no one put a mask
on the guy and it's because of what we
call management by optics okay it's the
optics of this is no big deal and we won
if Trump hasn't been seen with a mask
once during the entire pandemic and he
hasn't and then he claims we've
basically won we can start taking apart
the pandemic response the White House
coronavirus task force rather if he then
shows up with a mask for the first time
the optics don't match III admit that
that's the case if you're trying to say
we won you don't start wearing a mask on
week 9 of the pandemic this is
management might by optics period and
that is very dangerous
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
all right I want to tell you guys about
something that's been sort of going on
behind the scenes at the show and maybe
it'll be interesting to you and it has
everything to do with people in my
audience who are never going to be
satisfied with this program for lack of
a better term and maybe naively over the
last few months maybe I thought that I
could satisfy them in some way and this
doesn't apply to everybody but there are
also people in the audience that
probably I should sort of be apologizing
to in the sense that I I think that my
naivete on this issue may have made the
show worse for some of you over the last
few months and here's the realization
that we've sort of come to as a point of
departure for what we're talking about
today it's become very clear over the
last I would say acutely the last three
months but more bigger picture over the
last year that there's a slice of the
left that's never going to be satisfied
with this program unless I just become a
different person with totally different
views and a different moral grounding
and essentially M no longer me and the
show is no longer this program now of
course the entire right is dissatisfied
with this program other than the people
who write to me and say I don't agree
with anything you say but I I just I
watch to see what your take is and I
appreciate you being honest about it but
in terms of the positions I take of
course the right doesn't agree with
almost anything that I say on this
program but there's also a contingent on
the left which is far louder in the
sense in a sense because they are at
least you know nominally part of my side
as the term is that is never going to be
satisfied with this program unless I
just abandon everything I believe in
take their positions so before I get to
that I told the story years I mean I've
been telling the story over the years
many times when I started the David
Pakman show back then it was called
mid-week politics it was just a one a
Wednesday program I was absolutely
horrified that somebody might write to
me and be mad that I said something they
disagree with or they might leave an
angry youtube comment or something like
that it was scary to me and I sort of
tried to play the show down the middle
for a while for a few weeks where I
would report the news and I would say
the left says this and
right says this and kind of leave it
there and it was a very boring show and
it was also unsatisfying because of
course I had opinions and I was keeping
them to myself and not really stating
them because of this fear and also
people got mad anyway right people
people disagreed that there were two
sides to many stories and they were mad
that I presented both sides as if they
were equal so the point is I quickly
realized that that couldn't be the show
it wasn't a satisfying way to me to do
the show and it wasn't very useful
either because I have an opinion that I
want to get out there so that this very
quickly became an opinion program and of
course now I'm used to the attacks and
the anti-semitic comments and thousands
of mm-hmm
excuse me angry angry youtube comments a
day or whatever the case may be
but over the last three to twelve months
it's become very clear that there is now
a slice of the left that is not going to
accept any position other than their
position and they won't stop calling me
a DNC shill or other terms unless I take
their positions and what I want to tell
you today is that it's not going any
further
you're not going to be satisfied with
this program and maybe this isn't the
program for you let me give you some
examples okay right now these are may be
relevant examples one is the never Biden
crowd okay
the never Biden crowd is never going to
be satisfied with what I say unless I
join them and say I'm never gonna vote
for Biden now I'm not going to do that
at this point based on what we know it's
conceivable Joe Biden could go on a
killing spree or something and I changed
my mind
but it's become clear that no matter how
I couch the reality that based on
everything I know right now Biden's
clearly better than Trump and I plan to
vote for Biden I could talk about the
Supreme Court I get doesn't matter it
doesn't matter what I say unless I
refuse to vote for Biden there's a very
loud contingent that shows up on my
Twitter and reddit and whatever they're
not going to be happy now the good news
is they represent a pretty small portion
of my audience and a pretty small
portion of the left but this is not
going to be a program for these folks
and they will call me a democratic DNC
shill unless I say never Biden which of
course helps Donald Trump not gonna do
it let's talk about another example this
relates to a woman named Terry
Tara Reid says Joe Biden sexually
assaulted her in 1993 now there was a
period of about seven to ten days where
I had a contingent contacting me
increasingly angrily saying David you're
terrible you're a shill because you're
not covering her allegations now over
time more and more clips have published
to my youtube channel now I believe it's
six in total where Tara Reid's
allegations are discussed has this
satisfied this slice of the left no of
course not because I'm talking about
Tara Reid now but I'm not saying the
right thing which I guess is Joe Biden's
a rapist and I'm not voting for him but
of course I'm not going to say that Joe
Biden hasn't been convicted of rape he's
not even accused of rape if I understand
the allegations correctly and the
reality is that either Joe Biden or
Donald Trump are going to be President
of the United States on dozens of issues
I prefer Biden now this is not some big
theatrical defiant performance for me
I'm living my life I'm doing the show in
advocating for the policies I support
and in November I will essentially have
two choices and I've made clear as of
right now which choice I'm going to make
I've not attacked Tara Reid's
credibility I've not come out and said
her story makes no sense I've not done
any of those things but this contingent
didn't really want me to just talk about
Tara Reid they want me to say never
Biden and they won't be satisfied until
I say that this is no way to run a show
if I'm going to kowtow to these slices
of the left that are hell-bent on
getting specific statements out of me I
could do every show about Tara Reid but
it's not just about covering it it's
about taking their position and if I
don't I'm a DNC shill and a bad person
this probably isn't the show for you
we've seen this in some other cases as
well I won't spend a lot of time on
these but when it comes to the Maduro
regime in Venezuela you know I've
pointed out the rhetoric that started
with Hugo Chavez it was very left
populist rhetoric it became an
authoritarian nightmare a corrupt
judiciary it can't be trusted the
country's resources have been raped and
pillaged by elites to the exclusion of
the majority and people write to me and
say David how dare you support American
intervention in Venezuela and I say no
I'm from South America I'm very well
acquainted with the history of the
region
disasters of American intervention but
Chavez was no hero and Maduro is no hero
and that they've been bad for the
country and they hate it so it's not
really about I support American
intervention which they know I don't
it's that I'm not praying at the altar
of Maduro they will never be satisfied
recently george w bush came out with
this just milquetoast statement about
unity around coronavirus and i said hey
george w bush is a war criminal but
compared to trump he sounds like a
normal person it's not praise of bush
i'm not rehabilitation as image and
immediately dozens of comments and
hundreds of Twitter and Facebook posts
saying you are rehabilitating the image
of a war criminal they will never be
satisfied unless I always say there is
no way in which Bush is better than
Trump
so my renewed effort is and this is my
pledge I don't care about what these
people think and I'm not going to let it
dictate the show you can leave me
comments on youtube or tweet me write me
email you know whatever maybe this just
isn't the show for you
like I I don't watch political shows
like mine but there must be some show
that takes these positions right like if
you're looking for an ever Biden show is
there a bite and never Biden show out
there I assume there is or if you're
looking for oh we love Maduro show or
I'm guessing that these shows exist much
like I can't open the eyes of a devout
trumpet they're closed off so are these
leftists on this slice of the left and
it's sad but I can't control it
all I can control is my show and I
apologize that over the last three
months there's been a naivete where I
thought maybe there would be some way
but it doesn't seem like there is
they're not going to be satisfied
everybody should watch the shows they
want read what you want come to your
conclusion conclusions but we're gonna
do the show this way and that's the way
it's going to be now let's get to
something positive which relates to
really great changes for the show that's
the next thing okay
very exciting we have increased the
duration of The Daily Show by 10 percent
now this might not sound like some big
Vick
but a year ago we increased the duration
of the show 10% we've done it again the
way we've done this is by cutting the
amount of breaks from the broadcast show
we have this our show on radio TV it
can't go longer than an hour there were
a commercial radio shows that in an hour
have 38 minutes of content that used to
be us
we've expand that expand that expanded
expanded we've now added another 10% to
the show making it nearly a full hour
show and that is fantastic you might
have noticed this week that we're able
to look at some stories in more depth
we're not gonna cram more into the show
it's just gonna let us do more depth for
the shows for the stories that we're
already doing I think it's a really
great thing we are also adding a daily
written digest of the show a lot of
people have written to me and said you
know David I prefer to read stuff I like
your perspectives I like the show but
it's easier for me to read on the
imaginary ding on the subway or whatever
we are going to be turning our daily
newsletter into a sort of written digest
of the show you can sign up for what
will become this in the next couple of
weeks on my website at david pakman.com
just sign up for the newsletter you'll
get all of it it's all great stuff you
can also sign up for that at david
pakman.com it will also provide a new
way to support the show but it's also
going to be free for everybody that
wants it for free really really great
stuff I am thinking of this virus phase
for the show I am thinking of it as the
process of a caterpillar becoming a
butterfly okay I use this analogy on the
bonus show yesterday we were a
caterpillar going into coronavirus
during coronavirus we are in the
chrysalis stage I'm going back to like
third grade science class we are now in
the chrysalis stage and my goal is that
we will come out of coronavirus
re-emerging as a butterfly less orange
of course than a monarch I don't want to
be like Donald Trump but as a butterfly
with a lot of great things and a better
program and all of these things so
exciting stuff and very very good news
looking forward to all of it once we get
past this difficult time we have a
voicemail number that number is two one
nine two david p this voicemail caller
asks a question i asked on twitter a few
days ago what if the armed coronavirus
protesters were groups of black people
would it be different how they were
handled take a listen to the voicemail
question hi david my question is when
protesters are blocking ER entrances
harassing nurses and bringing rifles on
state capitol grounds where are the
police
right if black people or any other group
did the same exact thing carrying guns
the police would be there in riot gear
arresting people but if you carry an
american flag in your white you can walk
any place you want with a rifle that's
my question thanks yeah
i am presenting the question without
comment check out my tweet about it see
what the reactions were and i want to
hear from you what if indeed the lion's
share of the lockdown protesters showing
up with long guns and i think some of
them even like bulletproof vest what if
they were mostly black folks how would
this this be covered in media how would
police react let me know what you think
we have a fantastic bonus show today we
will talk about risks of additional
starvation as a result of the Coronas
about coronavirus pandemic on the bonus
show and much more get instant access by
signing up at join pakman.com or
becoming a patron at patreon.com slash
david package
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
David I've put a link right underneath
this video